catherine is in canada hi Catherine how
are you I'm good thank you so much for
taking on such an honor to talk to you
YouTube what's up so I do have a
question my husband a little back well
my husband I went to a free financial
course yesterday that we should resolve
money and we're like okay what the heck
let's just go it's free and they were
saying it's better to do a line of
credit instead of a mortgage because you
can pay more of the principal and
interest at the same time instead of a
mortgage and on the drive home I husband
I were like oh would this be something
baby would do what would she do to us
I'm calling in I need to know what you
think it's a scam okay they want to
charge you 3000 or 4000 dollars to show
you how to do that right it was free no
no you went to the free seminar yes yeah
but didn't they have a course to sell
you on how to do this they want you to
join their thing no no he said it was
free they do everything they'll show you
what to do and everything they just want
to help people get out of debt and pay
off their mortgage faster yeah okay but
I don't know that's it's all it's also
false
okay so aside there's a scam there's a
scam going around it's not a scam but
it's just a it's just a ripoff where
they're charging three or four thousand
dollars and teaching people to get a
HELOC and then use that to pay pay their
mortgage into their HELOC then pay it
back and forth and and they try to
convince you that that pays off the
mortgage faster here's the deal okay
whether you have a HELOC or whether you
have a mortgage there is only one way
that it gets paid off when you pay the
amount that you owe called the principal
and when you pay the interest that you
owe okay and of course the faster you
pay down the principal the less interest
there is in either case that is true on
a mortgage that is true and on a on a
HELOC it is true okay so what happens is
that your interest is calculated on a
mortgage monthly mm-hmm and it's
calculated on a HELOC monthly so an
example a simple example would be if you
had a sick
percent which would be unusually high
but it's an easy example that's a half a
percent a month six percent divided by
twelve okay so whatever you owe that
month in outstanding principle 0.05
0.005 on that which is a half of a
percent is your interest amount anything
else you pay above that reduces the
principal in either case it's called a
simple interest calculation and that's
how it's done in both cases so there is
no magic pill to get out of debt
yeah the way you pay the way you get out
of debt is you pay off the debt and it
doesn't change if it's a mortgage or if
it is a HELOC so these guys are running
something I can't tell exactly because
they even figured out where they're
going to charge you yet but it sounds
like that other thing that was going
around a few years ago